my pal Anton Michael Hall is here and
that does sound like Simon kabbadi all
right sounds like we're just listening
to the Sam just playing The Beatles man
are you a Beatles fan I'm trying to put
together a Beatles you gotta be real
hits channel how are you doing good
right now yeah right there sir
yeah we're just going to know could they
start the Beatles channel here on Sirius
XM and we were just talking about how
you literally can't you could play The
Beatles anywhere and it's relevant it's
just one of those things that just kind
of translates everything yeah also and
we talked also about 70s movies and Sam
is not a huge fan of a lot of 70s movies
I'm trying to spit out great 70s movies
I mean I acknowledge there are amazing
movie end in the 70s but like if you
take out those you know AFI top 100
movies generally speaking I just can't
get into it
hmm what do you think that movie that
this is defined to you a lot of your
stuff within the year like we started in
the 80s what's a good day TS defining
fellow I was thinking 70s so I was going
to say apocalypse I think personally
have a different take on it we all
deserve one I think it was the last
decade of like the filmmakers there was
a lot of great movies made in the 70s
right so well so what's one you think
defines a seventies really well uh good
question which one does oh there's so
many who would you say Jim on I don't
know I mean I I said Cooper Cuckoo's
Nest I was just with true you I Tommy
I'll see what he did for it was just
yeah that that's an amazing original but
you were talking about movies that even
I hadn't even heard of like those those
don't have to noon no no of course not
darn that's incredible yeah but I mean
like you're Alan Alda movies that you
were talking about but they were like
80s we had Alan Alda an earlier we had
it seems like old times on bursting with
her cheating they're just [ __ ] each
other once a year and what was the other
one it was uh for Jason's with Carol
Burnett I love them isn't that great for
Middle Ages on a boat
yeah but it was pointed we good it had
it was a good script it was about
getting older and how your life changes
and the one guy starts banging this like
20 year old ditzy girl and it's like now
is I'm in my forties I kind of get it a
little bit is it tough now for an actor
because I go what other things we were
talking about is that like stories
aren't being told so much in theatrical
releases anymore you know it's all sort
of blockbuster action
blockbuster like it feels to me just as
an onlooker
yeah like studios are after the
guaranteed to get X million dollars in
the opening weekend and then we got the
next action movie over here in the next
superhero yeah you know I think that
you're absolutely right I mean that's
part of the that formula in the targeted
films and ten polls and all those so I
don't have meeting those films yet yeah
no but you get a script what do you look
for good writing I mean the conflict I
don't know I I think in both in comedy -
I don't know what do you look for
generally it's good I don't know I think
I'm saying yes I can do it poor
decision-making by the casting director
I really like watching a movie that you
become aware of time when you're reading
anything you're like what am i doing
women this is not interesting so I think
you want to get lost and I guess that
suspension of so much belief right hime
and you and you know you mentioned
Apocalypse Now you know Martin Sheen
right no no no but I we would she and I
go to a church and Mel but we see in
their manic is a beautiful guy man he's
an interesting he's such a great actor
he's been great in so many films um I
did meet him as a kid on breakfast Cody
came to the set once oh really oh yeah
yeah it was great was that back when he
was or was he sober then or is he still
Drake Dyke is Martin Sheen went to that
sing Apocalypse Now or he had that melt
out and he's like right for many many
years now was that back when he was
still in his wild days know was recently
a few weeks ago no no we when you saw
him said the broad on the Berkeley
holdups yeah 1984 came to visit Emilio
yeah was he and that's back then it was
not this totally cool not like a dad
beat yeah so maybe he had already
cleaned up that was like a couple years
after Apocalypse Now that that story is
fascinating right during the making of
it you know how everybody you know
because I think Coppola was just I mean
it's a masterpiece but it you know he
was kind of he didn't know what he was
doing it was like something out of
control I think at that point those
stories are always good in hindsight
yeah like when you do in a movie and
your [ __ ] star it melts down drinking
and punches the mirror and bleeds and
you film it that's not a great story in
the moment now that's a great story
twenty years later you're like oh that
was amazing that it came together I rose
yeah when they talk about like what a
maniac like Kubrick would be to some of
the women that were in his movies really
well but yeah like I was like the
documentaries like they say like The
Shining like he was a maniac to work
with on that movie but then in hindsight
you're like oh but was he just drawing
out these those manic performances I
actually had the pleasure meet you at
once and
he told me I think I mean this isn't
really talking about school but I think
that Shelley Duvall at that time you
know like whatever demands were and this
and that and Jax take on it was you know
Kubrick was like strategic and surgical
about it and I think that I think when
you watch that film there's a bit of a
meltdown unfolding and yes but that's
something that's a whole other category
Kubrick that's what that's yeah that
they were saying like he would treat
Jack Nicholson like a million bucks and
then Sally over I didn't come I didn't
plan on saying this but it's interesting
because you never know I mean I will
also read some that Coppola said which
is when he looks back his life it you
know that when you make something it
just reminds him of where he was at that
point you know yeah now the film that
his wife made about the making of
apocalypses I think Martha dark ties
incredible heart Siddhartha's like
equally fascinating right so I mean it
just it's interesting they're kind of
marks certain period of times did you
bring it to me Brando I didn't I didn't
yeah cuz they said he was really
difficult that and like you know Coppola
hood brought him back from The Godfather
and The Godfather and then II you know
he's kind of 10 years later just kind of
be in a dictum I'm a set and being
difficult
yeah the human condition I guess so
you know this film you're doing is with
Brad Pitt I mean you've worked with
almost everybody um and how did this
come about you this is based on the
firing of Stanley McChrystal to nebulous
movie yes sir Wow and what happened was
it was an article called the runaway
general years ago that led to Hastings
writing the book the opera's which is
fascinating in a great voice as a writer
it's a shame he's not with us
but what would Michaud did and with Plan
B and Netflix was to say look we're
going to kind of fictionalize this and
it's inspired by okay and the film you
know it's people going to get whatever
they get out of it but it's certainly
you know I think it's a really great
piece of work I'm really proud a Netflix
is amazing what they're doing they're
doing all these original films like they
put a hundred million into this new
Scorsese movie I heard with Pacino De
Niro passion is always risen yeah what's
that about you know I don't either but I
mean they're spending so much money and
getting like they got you think of Brad
Pitt they trying to get these guys for
these are it's got no theatrical release
just coming out on Netflix is that weird
for you you know what's so interesting
GMOs in the car you say it and the
driver was so cool he's from Jamaica and
he said you know what man without naming
name them you know television it was
getting a little bit but you know time
for a new model
and this is a good right he was sailing
every kid's he goes I got 4k in my car
man the image at home and he was in
support of it so I think when there
whenever people resist change at any
level but I think what they're doing is
incredible I mean I'm honored to be
working for them and I saw the latitude
that plan B and mr. Michaud had in
making a film around the world where you
know all the former issues of the
opening week and all these other things
I think are although still in play
they're not restraints it does it take a
lot of pressure off you that's kind of
like you know you're not obsessed how
much did it make and what I was talking
about that Katelyn I who works with
strategy PR about you know the model
what Netflix is great because what they
do for a living they're allowed to you
know help and support the film beyond
that first weekend you know so look man
there's a lot of ways to work I did
something for them and they said like
that I did a lot of press for it the
first week and they said like you don't
have to do they actually tell me you
don't have to do it you could do in a
couple of months
they're like it lives forever here you
don't have to obsess about because you
get so used to like who's gonna watch
that fur and this is just relaxing I'm
like all right they don't see it now
they'll see it in [ __ ] six months
whatever it's there right and it's
interesting because I had a different
opinion a couple years ago we kind of
glorified traditions right so like the
movie theater I read once Orson Welles
was like and this is years ago before
one had a big screen but one of these
books have on wells he said you know the
movie going experience people go and sit
in the dark it's like a temple like
experience and they look up at a screen
you know me and and the television at
that point this is probably the forties
he was saying is over in the corner you
walk in a room went down there you could
the world has changed man and I read an
article mr. Michaux last night he's like
I like watching movies at home yeah
people have to kind of get beyond
whatever they get beyond and plus
Citizen Kane we were just talking about
this before for talking about Harrison
wells yes and that was an editorial
thing too with it the lights and and and
with the mirrors and with the shadowing
so for him
seeing that in the theater must have
meant that he was inventing it and watch
this great documentary on that floats a
few weeks ago man and it's literally he
was inventing that stuff he didn't know
you know did you see the war the world
wars and wealth no no it's on Netflix as
well I literally just watched it but you
see him like I mean he was inventing
stuff even before he's in a radio studio
well and it's all done live but it's
like this big room and this person's
doing this sound effect and he's like
you know he's Easy's he's being the
conductor of this amazing orcas
to create this programs when it comes
down to ultimately creativity at the
same time nobody works alone man I mean
other than Jim when he's on stage yeah
but it smelled like amoebas right right
it's such a community experience you
make a movie man there's 200 people man
but we're all in it
yeah and used to it's funny we have a
mutual friend I live we've ever talked
about it I'm your pretty good friend of
Mike Tyson
yeah no choice I haven't seen him in
years oh you haven't here quite a while
did you seem in Vegas no I did I saw his
show when I was in bed isn't it great I
thought that was great what he did man
yes what spike did did you and you
actually went on HBO but I hadn't seen
alive I'm just saying I love that they
collaborate on that and he was so cool
because people didn't know that I knew
him since I was a kid and he's so funny
man how did you meet him Paul Gleason
after we did the Breakfast Club those
big fight fan he took me the garden I
was kid man I was like 17 and he
introduced me to Tyson and we became
buddies man he's you know he's a lot fun
you know there's a lot there man is he's
a really smart guy in with through a lot
of stuff man he's a much different guy
than you expect yeah like he's more
insightful like yeah when you just see
someone boxing and talking [ __ ] you
that's what you expect from the day and
then you talk to him and they have he's
like got all these things about
self-esteem and self-worth interesting
guy yeah and yet hoback's documenter was
also great yeah
that was really good right but CIT you
know I didn't I hadn't met him at that
point when James told I was talking
about so I saw that I was like oh it was
kind of nice to see that other side of
this program who I had an opinion on
right on yeah I mean he's got
philosophies and and and he's well
thought out at like almost everything in
his life it seems like he's got a
philosophy behind he's got a
self-awareness of what he has in his
head that you wouldn't think would be
there it just flashed me no cuz I'd
totally agree with it I also feel like
you know you'd live the lightest in
terms of fight game he'd lived a life as
a lean he's also been Joe Lewis yeah
yeah look at his life for me ups and
downs man nobody's immune to it you know
so I'm just grateful that he's still
he's got a bunch of kids and you seems
like very happily situated then you guys
got a theater together or something
dude we went and we - we had a double
date with these girls we saw some play
years ago it was fun we'd go to clubs I
mean it was great it was like a big
brother and we came to much but when I
did many was great would you mind going
on a double date with Mike Tyson
I would love to he's married now but his
wife is lovely I'd go out if I knew a
girl amazing I could get to go and mike
is like me Kiki we'll go out but you got
to bring someone I would find someone to
go I would happily find someone to go on
a double date with them
you know cuz I was very nice so it was
cool he was a great friend and look
forward to seeing me it's weird isn't it
weird though when you meet people that
you wouldn't normally meet in shoulders
whether it's actors or comedians or
fighters or and then you don't see them
for a long time you make these really
weird connections with people that you'd
never never have access to otherwise
it's so funny said that because I was
with Kelly LeBrock this weekend we're
doing a con and Convention those are fun
man because it's very humanizing you
know I like going out and just having
fun of those things um and I just I was
having a similar kind of Epiphany this
weekend how good a friend she is to me
and how long I hadn't seen that and how
well she actually knows me even though
like we're saying friends come and go
but when they're there but over time
there's an appreciation that grows how
long you worked with her 17 men but we
had some really cool insightful
conversations and she was helping me
with something that I was talking about
and I realized that thing about a friend
man it's like wow yeah he realized how
when you're younger you just go on and
be friends and then you know idiot you
do have friends what do you do by the
way and you also write write and you
also have no idea probably in the
industry like because you could spend
all this time without seeing people
right like you don't know until the
years pass who is actually your friends
so if this acquaintance that I knew then
and don't know now yeah and I said this
along I mean I'm not planning it I just
life is such an incredible gift right
it's a personalized experience at the
same time it's group therapy it's a
classroom you know so I think that a lot
of us we beat ourselves up and we think
we don't have this or that but back to
friendship I had a great few
conversations with killing it would
reminded me of the value of our
friendship so we use a comic-con you
kind of just wanted you to do it just
assigning with people a mop and they pay
to get picture I mean it's yeah but you
know it's fun it's fun to do those men I
don't you know did you have did you have
to get to a place where it was fun like
I would imagine no I think what it is it
surprised me because it benefited me
more than I thought I was being useful
because it really helped me to just get
out of LA wherever Elsa was in like
right and go there and meet some fans
and hang out and nobody was relaxing
because you said he's a fan of so many
things and people yes it's buck sting
and Spartacus as a creative person or
not so for me was helpful as a person to
start doing those over last couple years
you make some money cool but I don't see
what I get and that interaction has been
very helpful how did you make sorry to
have helped make this jump to because a
lot of guys who are really famous from
their young have a hard time when they
get when they
become adults and what what for you is
the one that tipped it like Jodie Foster
pulled it off but she went to college
and took a little break what tip did
feel like okay I'm going to be good as
an adult - well it wasn't that thought
out to him I wish I could say it was it
was more like just having a hard head
and wanting to work but just realizing
over time I'd made bad choices both in
my career in my life and at the same
time getting back to myself but hey man
you can do better you can it's about the
experience of who you're working with
the people you're with men and so push
yourself further with your downtime for
you like what else had happened we like
I didn't get a job for a year what's the
law as you eyes I mean I've gone
probably two years without jobs at
different points in my life so and it's
difficult because in our industry you
know it's hand and mouth so you gotta
learn to appreciate and you and who else
is in this film with you obviously it's
Brad Pitt I saw the poster in LA
Jonathan pointed out to make Topher
Grace okay Topher Grace are great actors
man Tilda Swinton Ben Kingsley Jesus
incredible and then this incredible
generation of brilliant young actors man
RJ Siler he's like a great comedian and
actor Emery Cohen all these really tell
you know Keith Stanfield look Heath I'm
not sure of his name but just a
beautiful assortment of very talented
actors and mr. recter man he did saying
he's truly a writer director disguised
someone to watch he made a really
powerful film I mean people decide
whether this for themselves but I'm I'm
honored to be a part of it I'm gonna be
working with with Brad and Dede and
Jeremy and Netflix and I'm just grateful
that I'm in a good movie I've done
enough that I don't want to watch it
started yeah yeah it's gonna be on this
Friday my Netflix and it's just this
Friday and then it just lives forever
did you know Brad before you might had a
versatile adjustment you know this
minimum said cool guy what's your first
meeting with him like is that a
read-through or what do they do to you
are you a little nervous walking up to
him I mean everybody's yeah he's cool he
puts you at ease ease it really please a
stand-up guy man he's really nice and
easygoing he's got a great sense of
humor you know on set I just kind of you
know gave him his space but he's great
he's a great producer but totally on the
level man he's down earth really cool
are you kind of past being nervous
working with big-name actors because
you've worked in somebody nah man
because I was I was amped and and
excited to work with him you know I'd
stayed the day that Tilda Swinton shot
you know you're always learning so I was
just grabbing from every word and
sometimes it's not from the cameraman
you know there was a prop guy in this
movie there was one of the coolest
people ever worked with Nick Billy David
gave him a cameo in it as a drunk
stumbling
Street was awesome I mean there's all
these connection points when you as you
know this gym when you travel and I love
being surprised you know by the
connections and the people it's not
always you know active actor obviously
it's you know it's a great collaborative
experience you know it takes a village
to make a movie - yeah totally
when you're a kid is it tough to go to
the transition of like convincing people
that you're not this kind of nerdy
little kid that you you know what I mean
because you get camps and so many movies
that become this one's iconic and the
next one's iconic the necklace iconic
and then people are just like that's
Anthony Michael Hall the person not the
character yeah I think that there was a
blur for me as a child man because it
was weird to get pigeonholed and you
know like all that crap and stereotypes
and all that stuff and I think it
motivated me as an actor just to go in
different directions and to make a
commitment of myself that you know I'm
going to keep working the rest of my
life and then I'll define whatever I can
do is landing in an actor's career right
Jimmy or even as a comedians like I'll
wind up here nah man you just woodshed
you work at it and then but does it make
you like did it make you like I'm going
to start hitting the gym I'm gonna get
really big or I'm gonna start doing it
I'm 39 where you gonna send down the
owner Billy absolutely and then I made a
couple bad move remember my parents
worked I'm like that was pretty lonely
she get back to being vulnerable but
literally they had that conversation me
I mean I'm being goofy but but yeah and
that was a hip reminder to me too man
like cameras don't lie so like as an
actor man you just you want to reflect
life in some way man you're not trying
to [ __ ] people really where people
treating you like these movie characters
you play like we get always Molly
Ringwald movies you did play this kind
of like this geeky dude who wasn't sure
of himself but then you're a real guy
you want to go out and meet girls and
get laid when you're 17 and are they
reacting to you cuz you're famous or
like you're that guy probably both I
don't know yeah
have you ever hooked up with a girl like
I've done this who's much hotter than
you deserve because you're famous or
anything better than that
no and the rooms well good laugh it's
your be honest that's it man that's what
has taught me - I think that you know
it's not an act like I've never
understood celebrity I'll be the first
to admit it I don't it doesn't even mean
anything to me I just want it to work we
even in college you know something Jeff
yeah first of all let me don't even
believe in that [ __ ] would you do you
feel now like secure in the sense that
like I figured out longevity like I have
anything man I haven't figured anything
I think it's about unlearning you know
realizing what you don't know that's
right that's what I mean I'm 40-minute I
got I think just just shedding skins and
realizing you know man
just keep going but ultimately you want
to appreciate the people in the
experience more and more and that's what
if that's been important to me recently
at the same time trying to raise my game
and be of service on any project where
it can be so and you know we talked last
time you were in about this too it's
something I've really jealous is the
fact that you know but we all love the
Heath Ledger as the Joker but you got to
do is see with him in that Harrison like
cool man you know I saw he was very very
quiet he was totally into what he was
doing you know I saw that he had this
friendship with Chris I remember reading
this was interesting it accepted I saw
it you know they were they were talking
about like Clockwork Orange and the Sex
Pistols
and there it is I mean his performance
is incredible man but there's all this
kind of animalistic stuff he does to
this behavioral stuff mean he's
brilliant in that film and but again I
don't really lean on actors or people
when I'm working men I just kind of
stick to myself and then I just try to
be prepared and conscious of the
experience and then I kind of save it
for whatever it was important with but
in the scene you know do you realize at
the moment that you're working with what
is going to become this not [ __ ]
amazing iconic character no I mean I
knew was gonna be a big movie there's no
way to anticipate dollars and so all I
can say is um I know I saw that he was
in a zone for sure man but at the same
time he was cool he was like a surfer
from Australia he was a great guy man
you listen to music in the morning and
he's just a person but when he's in that
when he's in that zone like I'm sad and
when he's when he's pulling off the
scenes that you see him seeing him pull
off wrote does it make you feel good
knowing like okay he's everybody's
bringing their a-game here I'll totally
this is gonna be a good product
yeah man because I mean the truth is I'm
a big fan of Christians and it was a
feats as well yeah and so I mean I was
all of those guys when I made the film I
got a small part but it was not about
that it was about the experiencial thing
like being there being a part of it I
was studying Nolan man no one kept
reminding me Hitchcock I don't know why
man he just felt see like such an old
soul and he's very you know very kind of
controlled and interesting variant quiet
but he's just it's like a Kubrick
when I was um one day this is a think
that's funny quick story I I didn't know
what to say to this dude I really didn't
and I was so honored and thankful to
Hina's wife Emma for putting me in the
movie in it and I happen to shoot on the
first day of filming on the movie and at
one point I got the balls I walked up to
my goat Chris so who are your favorite
directors I was like two guys my Golf
Course doesn't even look at means we're
both staring straight ahead he goes this
was great he goes Ridley Malick
and then like a three-second pause and
he goes in Kubrick for a sense of
control I'm in terrible British accent
but he goes in Kubrick for a sense of
control and at that moment I knew I'm
going to leave this guy but really he
took the time to say that so he was like
if he's into Ridley Scott Malik and
Kubrick and I want wild wide attentive
control well I think cuz I think that
he's got such a mind man it's like his
movies are playing on a lot of themes
he's working with memory and time and
dreams I mean look at his work you have
to have a clear vision and can have a
discipline about how to control all the
elements yes sir and I think like
Kubrick you're dealing with a major
intellect that it also was chess to him
somehow I mean I don't know man I got a
knife through education but I read a lot
and I was really studying Qbert long
before I had a chance to speak with him
I was going to do this movie full metal
jacket and I had the opportunity to
speak with the great Kubrick and my
first conversation my knees were
knocking I'm at Sheridan premiere I was
like making weird science with John
Hughes and and a new cubicles gonna be
calling me and we're not getting into
too many of the details of it you know I
was on the phone I'm like 17 years old
and he started talking about Eisenstein
and Chaplin and I was like yeah and all
these years later I mean there's so much
I would encourage anybody to study
Kubrick man is incredible but anyway
back to Nolan I tease that that kind of
mine I was yeah just watch this guy were
you know one to shut up when you're
honest you are we offer the Matthew
Modine role in Full Metal Jacket yeah
that was the role no that one yeah yeah
yeah and unfortunately just for not
getting you know I'm not going to cry
about it was just a difficult experience
it didn't work out for whatever reasons
but I only look back man it's probably
the only thing I would consider a regret
that it didn't
work out because I so admire but I so
love his work and was so honored to have
a conversation with ya but you never
know where even if a great one like that
you never know where would it went after
you might have done a movie after that
that wrecked everything to like so you
know yeah you you and the really good
career ending you guys know about that
yeah I mean he I saw a couple
documentaries that opened my mind up to
stuff I didn't even know about was going
on all you need any directed that are
you a conspiracy guy totally oh I
already dancing not an asset you know
about this I don't believe it's alright
Roy does he do i watch that one I've
seen that documentary talk documented
that guy is like so the theory is that
Kubrick directed tell me what Roy tell
me with his here short bus yeah that is
smart they went back to some of his
movies and they compared the moon
landing the video of that to some of his
movie the way I was shot the way the
exact way it was shot and there's a lot
of similarities and then it goes into
the shining and he had implanted a lot
of different hidden meanings inside the
center right and sort of theory yeah
exactly what people can find out for
themselves but it which it would which
opened my eyes to that The Shining was
actually a personal a personal catharsis
for him based on 2001 and what happened
before that which led to the moon
landing right he got to see the movie
though alright I will know he didn't
Terry there's anyone points to be maybe
you got actually study it's heavy I
don't even I can't even I'm not smart
enough to and was and and did he said
does that mean so the moon landing or
was faked entirely or or or not but the
people say that they went there but that
footage was faked just to make sure that
they show because we need beautiful
footage because the powers that be and
were saw that he had done such a
mind-blowing ly realistic job with 2001
right there was some recruitment done
there and that it could have been faked
so who knows no I believe they land on
the movement we have to end this because
our show our skill our show actually
ends the story will cut us on we got to
go yeah yeah we they would say the
government is cutting and so a regular
this I would come back they will notice
real the moon is real antsy Michael hold
on cheese but it's real it's
you